the physiological components of these
depressions which I'll now mention uh
which can go on for months or even years
uh affect
multiple hormonal systems sympathetic
nervous system and depressed patients uh
surprisingly are very inflamed they have
much inflammation in the brain and much
inflammation in the body and that's
because stress precipitates inflammation
in the brain and the body and I think
the reason that so is that in very early
thousands of years ago
when individuals
uh perceived the danger of stress they
had a full-blown stress response uh to
uh premonetorily protect them if they
got into a fight or flight or Mortal
struggle uh with another being and I
think for that reason uh stress
precipitates uh the stress response even
now so that if uh emotional stress like
public species public speaking causes an
activation of the stress response and a
change in in many of these physiological
parameters that I mentioned inflammation
increase is in stress hormones
and a variety of other changes that
adversely affect body so that because of
these changes depression is also a
systemic disorder
so that patients have premature
coronary artery disease stroke diabetes
and osteoporosis and that shortens their
lives by Seven Years
and so it's a major medical emergency
actually to have depression and I think
that's poorly understood that it's
associated with severe and long-lasting
physiological changes that shorten the
lifespan and that the depression needs
to be treated and that before the
depression is treated perhaps uh
prophylactic medications can be given to
decrease the propensity to coronary
artery disease stroke diabetes or
osteoporosis